what's going on guys happy almost New
Year's maybe it is New Year's depends
upon when you're watching this
so that means another year of breaking
your resolutions and another year of
movie releases guess what 2015 was great
it doesn't stop there's so many good
ones and we're gonna preview it for you
right now and we've got an awesome duo
to preview it with oh man look at this
dream team first you know from profiles
with Malone and Manson and Access
Hollywood Scott mance and she is the
other half of profiles with Malone and
mance and she's doing some super fun
stuff on screen junkies plus Alicia
Malone will cook about this year this
past year 2015 thumbs up or thumbs down
a thumbs up okay
thumbs up boom there you go that's our
2015 wrap-up moving on 20 we've talked
ad nauseam about 2015 so I want to look
ahead because we just had we had our
Star Wars we had our Avengers we had our
Jurassic world alright thank you
wonderful an embarrassment of riches
2016 is this gonna be a big year yeah
it's gonna be huge especially if you
love coming books oh yeah a lot of comic
book movies a lot of sequels lot of
science fiction movies yeah same as it
ever was
same as it ever was nowadays the old
boss same as the new boss right off the
bat I want to know a couple that each of
you are excited about I'm really excited
about Hail Caesar this looks like a
great crime caper once again which is
what they do best but set in 1950s
Hollywood which seems so glamorous to me
well the other thing about the Coen
Brothers and Hollywood the last time
they've really meshed like that at what
success was Barton think from 1991 and
that was one of their best movies see
put the count brothers in Hollywood with
George Clooney you get gold yeah Scott
keep talking what's a movie that you're
looking forward to no question about it
no surprise here but 2016 the movie I'm
most looking forward to is Star Trek
beyond what Star Trek needs to
commemorate its 50th anniversary is a
Skyfall a movie that's not just a great
Star Trek movie but is a great movie
period and I think this will be it
I Oh shots fired shots fired I'm firing
back here because what Star Trek beyond
I think will do
is captured the magic and the uniqueness
of Star Trek which was great characters
stories that meant something I have so
much hope that Star Trek beyond will be
a great Star Trek movie because if it's
not I'm going to cry let's get one more
from you Alicia that you're really
pumped about it's a smaller film because
I love Indies it's called lala land and
this is directed by Damien Chazelle who
did whiplash and then stars Ryan Gosling
and Emma Stone a musical what where Ryan
Gosling plays as jazz penis he falls in
love and aspiring actress played by Emma
Stone so those two fantastic together
plus Damien Chazelle with flash he shows
great promise
it comes out July 15 so I could be wrong
again but all signs point to this
there's going to be a fantastic film one
more from you one more for you that
you're really like Kelly for I really am
pumped for Captain America Civil War
because rectify the Russo brothers and
Captain America and Winterson Winter
Soldier it's I think you all agree it's
the best movie in the MCU that is right
there when a soldier felt like a mini
Avengers movie a lot of people are
saying that civil war is going to feel
like an actual Avengers well well you've
got Robert Downey jr. as Iron Man in
this movie so that does elevate it also
it's such a great story
brothers torn apart that's the
interesting thing for me watching the
the trailer that was released well at
the end when tony stark says we used to
be friends I mean that gives you chills
that's that's Marvel's biggie it's not
their only one but their biggie
well let's shift gears and move over to
DC's big one Batman V Superman I was
looking forward to Batman vs Superman
until I saw the trailer where it
appeared that they gave away the entire
plot I think it'll be good visually I
just hope the story is there as well
because that's where Zack Snyder often
falls down Henry Cavill who plays Clark
Kent and Superman yes I feel like they
should have given him one more really
good chance to make a great Superman
movie before they lumped him in with
Batman and then started doing their
version of the SCU
I want to see Henry Cavill I want him to
WoW me as Superman and he didn't do that
last time yeah okay another
superhero film that people are excited
about trailer got a lot of buzz Deadpool
Deadpool looks like a lot of fun I'm
glad that they've gone with the are
writing Ryan Reynolds himself is a huge
fan of the character and he looks like
he's having the best time ever
a lot of one-liners lot of little quips
but it looks like it's gonna be bloody
and gory and a lot of fun another one
that they're trotting out a solo
character film doctor doctor straight
could you watch a better cast a better
person to play Doctor Strange have
Benedict Cumberbatch and also the
director - Scott Dickerson yes I just
remember saying a couple of his horror
films and terrifying so I like the idea
that it's going to have that kind of
horror element to it because it's sort
of coming from a director of horror
films and deals with the occult so
you're gonna have a different kind of
tone which is already great because
it'll already stand out from the other
characters in the MCU we got to give DC
equal time here Suicide Squad
that's another biggie - I'm unsure about
this one as yeah I do like a lot of the
actors in it Margot Robbie she looks
very cool as Harley Quinn oh yeah Carly
Quinn is a character that I really
wanted to see on screen particularly the
way she works with the Joker and yeah
having him played by Jared Leto who's
obviously so good at playing dark and
disturbed people and he completely
transforms with every role but the
trailer didn't grab me I just don't know
what the tone is gonna be like they
haven't established these guys in other
films they have to do the job of
establishing all these things and then
giving them you know got some big
animated films coming out this year
DreamWorks is getting at us with Kung Fu
Panda 3 unless a Jack Black it's sort of
the role he was born to voice it's so
great at it sounds like he's having a
great time and you know the movies do
very very well with their perfect family
films I know the Panda
yeah finding Dory from Hitler yeah
Finding Nemo I'm excited about this I
mean how long has it been since finding
Nemo mr. Degnan
12 years 12 years in MO I think a lot of
people were calling for more and now
they finally bringing out dory film and
dory was one of my favorite characters I
can't wait to see where they take her
character particularly because she's
have much memory Pixar has a hard time
doing anything wrong so well well you
know that but they do do things wrong
when they do sequels cars who wasn't
great and news monsters University they
were okay that's a great point Scott I
want to ask you about one other animated
movie the Angry Birds movie this is a
movie that feels three years too late
yeah well it just feels like an obvious
business ploy yeah it is the most puppet
is anyone playing Angry Birds anymore
but it's good Jason Sudeikis yeah boys
the voice cast is good they got some
talent in there but yeah if you still
play Angry Birds let us know in the
comments below okay shifting gears there
are some big directors releasing movies
this year oh yeah Oliver Stone Oliver
Stone movie I like that combination I
just like what yeah gets its hands on a
conspiracy type movie that is when
Oliver Stone shines hello Natural Born
Killers but yeah hey it's Joseph
gordon-levitt he looks great as snowden
from that little bit that we've seen and
that story itself the true story is so
fascinating Spielberg's back again
BFG I love the look of this teaser
trailer it looks like a horror film
don't get out of the bed don't go to the
window and as someone who grew up
reading Roald Dahl yeah I'm so excited
to have it back plus the music at the
end just reminded me a little bit of
Harry Potter a little bit of hte
spielberg is back with his kid
family-friendly but slightly spooky
magic ha I want the Spielberg magic I
want the Spielberg that I grew up with I
want the Spielberg that surprised me why
me you know really gave me a great time
never turn to form for the kind of
Spielberg movies that we love oh yeah we
mentioned Gosling earlier
he's coming up in Shane Black's new film
with Russell Crowe your countrymen the
nice guys love this it's 70s again kind
of a crime caper Russell with the Brawn
Ryan with all his quirkiness yeah I love
the look just to see Russell Crowe
loosen up and have some fun he takes it
so seriously as an actor and he's a
great actor so I should but he needs he
needs to have some fun we all know
Hollywood loves the crap out of sequels
so let's talk about some of the biggies
nothing dull what are you talking about
Zoolander - do me a favor both you give
me your best blue steel right there I'm
cautiously optimistic about it
Zoolander is one of my favorite comedies
it's so clever and really stupid walk
off for so many quotable fun moments
another film with a long gap between its
first one and its sequel Independence
Day resurgence you know in the penance
day when I came out on Independence Day
weekend in 1996 yeah it was just the
ultimate popcorn movie yeah it's really
enjoyed it at the time but I don't know
I'm sure about this resurgence such a
generic title well also know Will Smith
in this movie yeah so you're taking a
big big huge Goldblum but you got to go
home you know what I personally I'm
excited for Matt Damon's returned to the
born to be a lot more paul greengrass
one of the best action director actual
hero is reborn paul greengrass obviously
he made the two best Bourne films
supremacy and ultimatum ultimatum was so
great
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna throw out a
couple more biggies that we haven't
mentioned ghostbusters female
Ghostbusters yeah I'm really looking
forward to this Paul Feig does such a
great job working with women working
with really funny women
it's a talented cast I think it's so
smart for them to do something
completely different if they're going to
reboot it I can't wait the Harry Potter
universe is opening up with fantastic
beasts I'm really really excited about
this film I am a Carrie Potter nerd oh
yeah and I loved the teaser that they
had with Eddie Redmayne did you did you
open that just a smidge and then you see
a moment with him in the wand I think
this is gonna be a different film a
grown up Harry Potter in 1920s New York
it's pre Harry Potter in New York yeah -
means we do have to talk about is one of
them as x-men apocalypse yes x-men
apocalypse director Bryan Singer nobody
knows or really gets the x-men universe
like Bryan Singer he makes magic when he
deals with x-men yes he does because he
gets it and so for him to keep doing
these like I mean at Days of Future past
I loved you got Oscar Isaac fresh off of
Star Wars The Force awakens playing
apocalypse speaking of Star Wars yes
how about row 1 yes now top a Star Wars
story so Alicia we're gonna be getting a
Star Wars movie every year for I don't
know how long yeah a little bit how
excited are you for rogue one very
intrigued this will be the first
spin-off film that they do that takes
place somewhere within the universe but
a different story for interesting Wow
we've hit so much there are so many that
we haven't hit but what is something
that is flying under the radar that
you're really looking forward to we're
looking forward to midnight special
directed by jeff nichols retaining him
with michael shannon they did such a
great job together and take shelter this
is about a young boy who has possibly
dangerous superhero powers and off they
go on a journey I love when directors do
small superhero movies more about the
character and very self-contained so I'm
a treat Alicia I can always count on you
for a gem that I have everybody Thank
You Scottie mine is the finest hours and
it opens very very soon in just a few
weeks at the end of January the Stars
Chris Pine Ben Foster and Eric Bana
this is rape based on a true story about
how the Coast Guard did a daring rescue
mission off the coast of Cape Cod in a
blizzard looks like the first must-see
movie of 2016 man another one to look
forward to you guys what movie are you
most looking forward to in 2016
let us know in the comments below tell
us why the best answer we're gonna send
you a screen name whose t-shirt I want
to thank this dynamic duo skal always a
pleasure Alicia my son thank you for
being here you smart wonderful talented
people profiles will own your mats check
them out check me out on Twitter thanks
for watching I'm how redneck bye bye
alright will eating this give me the
Christmas spirit it'll give you whatever
Beaufort Brimley has I can tell you that
there you go oh let it in let it in
Wow I'll come back with your knife
someone shot since I've eaten worse
things